I'm not going to write anything that
doesn't reflect me or that I can't see
myself being a part of it's one of the
reasons why I loved the Bridgeton books
because even though the characters were
originally I assuming all white I could
see myself in those characters there was
a universality there and to be able to
bring that to the screen in a way that
was representative was exciting I assume
they were all white too weren't they all
white Juliet yeah I don't think I ever
said so but yeah I mean that's what I
was doing and I just have to say
my feeling toward Shonda land and
Netflix are the way that they have
brought the series to life my overwhelm
feeling is gratitude because they were
able to turn this world into a diverse
and inclusive World in ways that by
myself I didn't know how to do and and
again coming back to this what you can
do with film versus books